we've been on the straight and narrow
all year
i'm killing soups carl i'm going to
start with you because the trailer
spoiled it so i'm not going to say
anything but you getting super powers
was like
a pretty big reveal so what was that she
gets the v this season
that's one of many right
so what was that like knowing you were
going into this season with that
information yeah it was fun uh you know
i've been having conversations with
kripke for a couple of seasons now
saying when is the point that we're
going to move beyond bribery and
coercion and finally get to that point
and i love the way that it was dealt
with because it was all wrapped up in a
moral dilemma it's and and it poses the
question how far are you willing to go
are you willing to turn yourself into
the demon in order to defeat the demon
and if you do what is the cost and i
think that every character on the show
gets posed that question and has to sort
of deal with it in their own way so it
was a lot of fun it was certainly a lot
of fun to play in that special effects
enhanced sandbox and
you know to exert some strength and see
some insane uh effect in the real world
yeah no i i will just say that i think
folks are gonna be
very surprised to see all of the new
twists and turns for season three but
that is just the tip of the iceberg and
although you guys sort of say it there's
a lot of like
moral and i think like very human
questions that are asked in this series
but you guys get to have a lot of fun
and karen i'm guessing the dance scene
was fun i'm hoping it was fun i don't
know it was just as you would imagine so
much fun
um i i might say it was the most joyous
day on set for kimiko
uh
it really is i mean she doesn't really
get to experience the joys of life ever
and so that day was really special to me
and her i mean the rehearsals leading up
to it i think really kind of uh not only
was it good for the dance number but it
also kind of strengthened to marine eyes
uh friendship and uh it fueled the other
emotional scenes as well so um it was
kind of like summer camp you know
going through a training together
oh yes more dance numbers more musical
numbers in general i know i hope so i
hope so um
i'm gonna go ahead and bring it to you
uh on this one about huey jack because
the trailer again has given us a lot it
says that you know billy's way maybe the
way which is such a weird thing from
huey after the events i know
so
what it like i feel like there's no path
that stays straight with this show and
everybody changes course so what was it
like changing course with that that sort
of like crux of what you guys are doing
yeah i love it i love that the show is
able to surprise me in its writing so
much uh just when i think it's going one
way it takes a completely different path
and i i love it i love being surprised
as you know i feel like you guys i feel
like viewers when i'm actually reading
scripts for the first time uh because
i'm like whoa we went there uh just it
blows my mind but you know this season
with huey i love that he starts out in a
happy place because we never
uh see that from him ever his life's
been pretty uh
pretty rough um for the last few years
just to see him like
enjoy himself was such an interesting
thing to play um and of course from the
audience's perspective he knows that
everyone knows that's all on shaky
ground that he's actually in the lion's
den but to have him go back to the boys
and go back to the old way is something
he very much doesn't want to do
um you know it's it's really rough on
him because he finally thought he had it
all figured out and and he was in a good
place in his life and then just go back
to the blood uh and the gore and the
carnage
is not a step that he wants to take but
it is necessary
yeah i think that's a lot of like moral
dilemma choices that they're all sort of
going through it with this one
and then there's also the fact that you
guys just keep adding new voices and
faces which is great carl i have to ask
you when you knew jensen was coming and
you knew more importantly that he was
going to be playing soldier boy
a such a different take
what was your reaction to that the
character and the jensen coming
well really um i i have to confess i've
never actually seen supernatural and so
i was really pretty oblivious to to that
aspect of his career but i had
conversations with kripke and i remember
kripke just vouching for him saying this
guy you're gonna love him he's the
greatest guy he's professional to a t
and he'll be he will fit right in and he
certainly did he arrived from day one
and
it's such an elevated game i think that
he naturally inspired others around him
to lift their game
and he was just a real real pleasure to
to have on set and he fit right in
immediately he was just became you know
one of the family
yeah he meant crippy's sort of
evangelicalizing him to the group before
he got there like like it's like is this
kid from my other family but you'll like
him
from my other family
yes
jack um i want to talk to you a little
bit about i'm glad amazon separated you
guys a little bit aaron because i think
it would have all been ship questions
but okay yeah we gotta ask you know
where where do we see the huey starlight
thing going in season three
well um they start out in a really good
place um and that was actually really
interesting because i feel like in
previous seasons we've seen a lot of
like when are they gonna get together
will they get together and it was really
cool to play this season and and to see
them in an actual relationship and to
see them like as a real couple that was
such a different aspect to their
relationship that i didn't know i really
wanted to see and and i did but then
you know as is typical for the boys
things start to go a little a little
south and navigating that
new relationship i i can't say much but
navigating that new relationship with
aaron was such a joy every day to come
in and and play that because i just i
don't know i love working with her and i
feel like we always find moments
that surprise both of us and it was just
such a
interesting season uh for those two
characters and i felt like we took them
to places we haven't seen before
for once i leveled the playing field
i show people
the real me
i mean they
love me i want to start with this one uh
for you anthony it seems like this
season just based on the previews is
definitely amped up and so much bloodier
than anything we've seen which is saying
a lot
uh what was your reaction knowing that
they were gonna go
go for it with this new tone and really
take it to places they hadn't done the
previous two seasons
i'm not sure that it is that different
totally to the first two seasons i think
the first two seasons are pretty you
know it's pretty full on um
i mean right off the bat we had huey's
girlfriend getting taken out by a train
which really set the tone of where the
show the exploding body
kind of set the tone didn't it it's easy
for a show like ours that does
dabble in the extremes of life and the
extremes of the medium it's easy to get
lost in the weeds a bit with you know
just being being gratuitous and
sensationalist and
i think one of the things that we have
done for sure is as the show has gotten
bigger and definitely there is that
you know they are they they have some
very creative ways of um
delivering ideas
shall we say i think there's a lot of
character a lot of it is anchored to
characters needs and i'll tell you the
other thing is we really get deeper into
character as well i think there's one
scene coming up for me in episode six in
particular
where um
where it is a pretty bizarre
psychological scene but it's actually
it's another view into the
the depths of this character so i i
actually think
across the board yes there's some pretty
startling
explosive moments but
um
most of the show is rooted in pretty um
pretty the in true needs of the
characters
yeah and i think that what's weird about
it is for as is like heightened as all
of it is you can imagine these like
strange workplace dynamics among these
folks we all sort of have them and aaron
with starlight i mean like
based on y'all's instagram and just what
we've gleaned and i watch a lot of these
you can tell you guys really have a
collegiate and family atmosphere both on
and off set
and so what was it like for you guys
coming into it this year knowing
especially the way homelander and
starlight their dynamic completely
changes too in season three
i feel like their dynamic kind of
has always been on
on that trajectory and i feel like it
kind of everything becomes the stakes
are just
higher because now we're co-captains and
i i think homelander is obviously drunk
on power and i'm a threat to his level
of power i think he perceives it as that
when i become co-captain i think because
the stakes are so heightened and as
we've been saying we're on opposite
sides of the moral spectrum that lends
itself to a really interesting tension
but
you're right we do get along really well
and i actually think that's great um
because
we're able to kind of
i don't know
the way we approach these scenes
together and talk things out and try to
find as many nuances in it as possible
and find new flavors each season in the
dynamic when you get along with the
other actor and you feel very
comfortable with them even if you're
playing enemies
it helps yeah absolutely and you're
right the cast is a very
it's a tight cast uh which is rare for a
big group of people yeah yeah yeah i
will say um eric gave uh anthony well
all of the cast but he gave you anthony
i say a different compliment he said the
greatest thing about he called you aunt
which i'm not going to be that familiar
but he said the greatest thing about ant
is that you
are the all like you advocate so much
for homelander and the most quickest way
to get you irritated is when people call
him a psychopath
it's true
it's true
yeah this is the best thing about that
though is this season i think we start
to see
the pressure that he's been under really
sort of like crack his facade in certain
ways and so not calling him that but
definitely showing that whatever
resolution he had is the foundation of
it is starting to break i think that's
going to be interesting and do you think
that is going to further dismiss the
psychopath idea or help people to come
to your way of thinking since day one
you know we've always tried to give the
the reason why this guy is like he is
and i think that's why the thing with
the psychopath thing is like you know
everyone has a a pretty stereotypical
idea of what a psychopath is and yes
there's no getting around it dude is
probably a psychopath but in terms of
creating a character like that's so
limiting because we're gonna get we very
quickly slip into moustache twirly
territory and and and i don't want to do
that and eric doesn't want to do that
either so i've tried to sort of erase
that word but
and and this season we do we we do
really get into this guy has been
basically a packaged
managed can of soup his whole life you
know he's always been wrangled and
and and forced to behave in a certain
way and
i mean
that's
you know it's such an unhealthy
unhealthy way to to to live you know we
we create celebrities we treat them so
bizarrely in the real world and then we
get perplexed when they do things that
are out of the ordinary that then we
disapprove of and it's like well what do
you expect and so this is
very much the trajectory of homie this
season is is you know it's the natural
evolution of treating someone like that
you know of course he's got a gog
complex and he you know he comes
crashing down but then he rebuilds we're
all we've got
it's up to us
i think i have
something maybe we can use it to blow
homelanders
brains out when you talk about the boys
i think everyone talks about taking it
to the next level so chase i'll start
with you
how do you feel they try to do that in
season three
oh i mean i felt like they they did it
and see
we did it i mean i don't know if i'll
work again afterwards then you did it no
um
it was it was a lot of fun obviously you
know there is those sort of moments
where we definitely top ourselves and
the deepest can't yeah i can't get it
right with sea life you just can't
figure it out especially not this year
um but you know crippy did keep it like
grounded like he does say sort of cover
the cereal box right it's sort of all
this action and
shocking stuff but the character
development was there it was it's it's
really interesting to see where everyone
goes and for me to see everyone else's
work
um but it's wild yeah it's uh we had a
lot of fun doing it so
well it looks like it and that's the one
thing you can really kind of tell it's
sort of like if you have fun watching
the boys it's like you have to assume
everyone had as much fun making it and
claudia what was interesting with your
character last season is like she just
again just showed us things that we
didn't expect you know that she's
political but also this like you know
spoiler alert superpowers and stuff so
what do you think about going into
season two knowing that so much of what
happened in season two is changing what
you're able to do in season three i mean
i was shocked in season two because i
didn't know that she had superpowers
until i got the script for that episode
so that was a shock to all of us yeah
that was that was a mind-blowing moment
no pun intended
i just remember yeah i just i just was
so in the dark and it was such a great
surprise um but in season three it's
really nice because we get to see a
softer side of her we get to dive into
her personal life and how that world
functions um and the people that make up
her personal life um which is it it was
so much
fun to just dive into
that part of her world to just find out
more about her because she's so kind of
surface in season two well she's very
unassuming and then
it was just yeah digging i mean queen's
move in silence is the best way i would
say with that one like she literally you
did not know and jensen i don't know if
you can see it i got my austin public
library shirt on shout out to texas and
supernatural
but you joining this anyone who's a fan
of that show anyone who's a fan of you
knows your relationship with eric and
just how cool it is and he said he felt
like it was a great family reunion but i
imagine it's almost different for you
because this was already his family and
you're coming in and it's like so what
was it like for you joining this
obviously great to re-team with him but
also i don't know it's different right
sure i mean yeah
being you know going from one cryptic
world into another quirky world was uh
uh
easy for me just because i i feel so at
home there but at the same time you're
right this i was a guest in somebody
else's house here i think because the
boss vouched for me these guys at least
gave me a chance they didn't kick me out
immediately and yeah no the hazing
happened through the writing i was just
about to say how did you have to do
anything
did they tell you everything they were
going to do with soldier boy before they
pitched it to you or is this something
where they're like we
captain america i feel like that's great
no no that's that's just go yeah it's
like all of us we we read these scripts
and we're like oh [ __ ]
uh
like i i had several moments like that
reading the scripts uh for this season
the hazing right out the bat my first
day on set i was there was nothing
between me and this new cast and crew
but a sock so i i was i got i had to get
comfortable very quickly the deep has
had a lot of i would say embarrassing
moments basically i'm thinking of all
the embarrassing things that you did in
season one and two and i'm just
wondering like
what is the most messed up one for you
because
it's great but like are people coming
get ready for season three yeah
[Music]
i guess i guess the most the most messed
up one was probably probably season one
where he gets kind of his comeuppance
and you know he gets assaulted and uh it
was just like
small room it was kind of hot and they
made this like torso of my own torso for
some reason well i know the reason
because there was you know to get some
you know it was like uh there was some
room to get in there
and like you know and he was like you
know
screaming action and and this it was
just a it was just a really messed up
day i'm like i need some air
uh she's going in there in the gills and
um yeah that was actually kind of
intense and it was disgusting so um yeah
but memorable and great television and
the memes bear me out really quick
jensen the psa how much fun was that
uh that was that was me and phil
segresia just literally coming up with
it on our own we were he just let me go
for
for what felt like an eternity and i i
just i was copying every angry actor
that i had ever worked with or heard
about uh in my life that was that was
that was easy it was fun yeah
makes you a soup for 24 hours
you're gonna need it
the whole point of what we do is that no
one should have that kind of power
i have to start with this carl said a
quote that i think will live in my brain
forever he said that you guys ran out of
fake blood by episode three which makes
me think considering how like visceral
and intense and frankly bloody this show
is how did you guys go about saying you
wanted to top
everything that you did already you know
i i think
we
get there by not trying to top it which
sounds very zen i always say to the
writer's room
you know the mantra in the room is like
don't go bigger go deeper we never ask
the question how do we top it we ask the
question of like okay what is the core
of that character that we haven't
revealed yet and how do we get deeper
and deeper to you know the the real
truth of who they are and then expose
that and dramatize that and torture them
and blow it all up but it's it's all
about learning more and more about the
characters as we go
and then just in the dramatizing of it
it just sort of seems to inherently lead
to these bananas moments um
because you know once you put
superheroes in the real world
superheroes are so absurd so once you
bring those laws of physics into
our world with our laws of physics
horrible things happen and it's it's in
that tension it's in that conflict that
the show really lives
i love that i will say i would say
honestly after maybe like season one
when folks got to know you and the show
i think people have been fan casting
bringing jensen here just knowing about
the working relationship that you guys
had and so seeing him finally suited up
for the boys was a very big moment but
what was it like for you like that was
such a long-running thing and your
relationship on that i'm sure is totally
different with this but what was it like
bringing him over to this and yeah
just seeing him in a very different role
i mean
look it was honestly the best on
supernatural i'd already put him through
so many different things over the years
and he can handle all of them like he he
can credibly
do action romance charm he can be scary
he's sort of the total package
and um and i sort of knew that so i
actually was excited because i
like i know what he's capable of and
when you're on a show for 15 years i
mean inevitably there's only so much
there's only so many colors you can show
for that character right and so i was
really
excited to get them in and and show like
a whole other
let show the audience you can do a
totally other character in a totally
other tone
and and still do it successfully so
um it was like a it was like a family
reunion you know and and and it lets me
write
really confidently because like i know
the actor so well
oh that's so great to say i mean now in
season three i would figure even with
the actors that you maybe just got to
know a couple of seasons ago you're
writing for them differently and one
that we've noticed is homelander folks
have already said you know
his lies just keep coming back to him
and he's like starting to crack which is
a very scary thing to think of because
he's already who he is but
what conversations you have with anthony
about where you were going with the
character because i feel like now
it's almost like the world is open for
what he could do when that's a scary
place yeah yeah the i mean in many ways
you could define the mythology of the
boys as like the slow unraveling of
homelander
with the understanding that eventually
they're heading towards a complete
sociopathic break
um and then that's an apocalyptic
problem and that's for sure going to be
wherever the show ends that's going to
be the grand climax of the show right
it's almost inevitable and so the
conversations i have with aunt a lot are
like okay so then what are
the guard royals and barriers that are
keeping him from just like destroying
the world
and and he still needs love and there's
parts of him that are human and he's
like
embarrassed by his own humanity but it's
it's there because that's who he is and
so that mess that like snake's nest of
psychology of like you know aunt and i
always talk about homelander as the
weakest character in the show
um like his ego is so fragile and he's
so easily insulted
um and he needs love so
nakedly um
that there's a lot that is keeping him
in control but like once he starts
realizing he doesn't need those things
um you know then then then god help us
all and last thing i'll say about anne
and why i love ant is
he genuinely he's better at hiding it
now than he used to be but he's
genuinely irritated when people call
homeland or sociopathic or the villain
or the bad guy
like he's better at being you know being
like but but he's like he's this he's a
misunderstood character
who never was loved and is doing the
best he can in this horrific
circumstance and i'm just saying like
i look i don't agree but
but that is the sign of a great actor
like that's what a great actor does it's
his job to advocate for homelander
because if he doesn't
no one will and um it's just really no
one will like
i admire i admire the [ __ ] out of it and
like homelander has these moments of
humanity and that's because of what ant
you know reaches for
you